fondée au moyen-âge dans le val de loire
l'abbaye de fontevraud a traversé les
siècles monastère jusqu'à la révolution
française elle se transforme ensuite en
prison avant de devenir un centre
culturel ouvert aux artistes
contemporains
avant le coc vide les visiteurs venaient
nombreux surtout pour voir la tombe
d'aliénor d'aquitaine
celle qui fut reine de france puis reine
d'angleterre en fait unique dans
l'histoire repose dans la nef de
l'église aux côtés de son mari et de son
fils le fameux richard coeur de lion
ils portent des armes elle lit un livre
là était proche des des troubadours de
la poésie des arts et c'est quelque
chose que nous on cultive encore
aujourd'hui à fontevraud
les visiteurs de la baie pourront aussi
aller au musée dans les anciennes
écuries de la cour d'honneur une riche
collection d'art moderne a été mise en
valeur
toulouse lautrec degas duffy
wangen de grands noms de la peinture
côtoient des antiquités venus du monde
entier
ces objets appartenaient à martin et les
oncles igman le couple présentés dans
l'exposition grâce à ce film a offert
900 pièces de sa collection personnelle
à la région et à l'état ce musée est un
reflet de leur appartement des choix
qu'ils ont fait pendant plus de 60 ans
il ya comme ça une ambiance humaine très
humaine il ya énormément de portraits ya
beaucoup de regards il ya beaucoup de
visages dans cette collection qu'ils
soient africains que mr océaniens ou
encore picturaux et moderne
l'épidémie de coville a retardé
l'ouverture du musée simple péripétie à
l'échelle du temps pour cette abbaye
fondée en 1101 à fontevraud art et
histoire continue à marcher main dans la
main
[Musique]